Ein ganz normaler Arbeitstag beginnt
für Christina Tipeva-Lawman:
Seit 20 Jahren steht sie auf der Bühne
in einem der größten Freizeitparks
Deutschlands,
im Phantasialand bei Köln.
Sie genießt jeden einzelnen Tag im Park.
Ich lebe in einem Märchen.
Da, wo die Menschen Urlaub machen,
da arbeite ich.
Ich brenne für meinen Job.
Ich könnte mir nicht vorstellen,
was anderes zu arbeiten.
Auch nach 20 Jahren auf der Bühne
liebe ich diesen Ort
und meine Arbeit immer mehr.
Die gebürtige Bulgarin tritt auf einer
der drei großen Bühnen im Park auf.
Die 47-Jährige ist in bester Form.
Hängend in der Luft einen Spagat
zu machen: ein Kinderspiel.
Was sie heute kann, verdankt sie der
Rhythmischen Sportgymnastik,
einer Sportart, die im kommunistischen
Bulgarien sehr beliebt war.
15 Jahre lang war sie Leistungssportlerin.
Bereits als Kind gewann sie Medaillen.
Nach der Wende verließ sie ihre Heimat –
wie viele andere auch.
Das ist ein schweres Thema
für unsere Generation.
Wir haben diese Sportart nicht nur trainiert,
wir haben sie gelebt.
Aber nach vielen Jahren harter Arbeit
hat sich alles drastisch verändert.
Der Kommunismus ist gegangen,
es kam die Demokratie,
aber vielleicht war es
eine falsch verstandene Demokratie.
Sehr viele von uns haben
Bulgarien verlassen.
Denn dort konnten wir uns nicht
weiterentwickeln, es gab kaum Arbeit für uns.
Und im Ausland waren
bulgarische Sportler willkommen.
1999 kam Christina nach Deutschland.
Nach zwei Jahren im Zirkus
entdeckte sie den Freizeitpark und blieb.
Mittlerweile steht sie nicht nur auf der Bühne:
Christina ist Teamleiterin
in der Abteilung „Künstler“.
Alle schätzen ihre Erfahrung
und ihren Teamgeist.
Sie ist fantastisch.
Sie kümmert sich um alles, was wir brauchen
– sowohl auf der Arbeit als auch privat.
Sie hilft uns bei Problemen, übersetzt für uns.
Ihre Arbeit ist hocheffizient und das
Wohlbefinden des Teams ist ihr sehr wichtig.
In jeder Hinsicht.
Seit vier Jahren tanzt Silvina
neben Christina auf der Bühne.
Aber auch außerhalb des Parks
unternehmen sie gerne etwas zusammen,
wenn Christina Zeit hat.
Denn sie widmet viele Stunden ihrer alten
Liebe, der Rhythmischen Sportgymnastik.
Im Bonner Turnverein springt sie
als Trainerin ein, wenn es nötig ist.
Sie freut sich, wenn sie Zeit mit den kleinsten
Sportlerinnen verbringen kann
und ihnen etwas beibringt.
Ich habe in Bulgarien
als Vierjährige angefangen.
Hier in Deutschland fangen die Kinder
etwas später an,
mit sechs oder sieben.
Sie können sich trotzdem gut entwickeln.
Dafür ist aber viel Leidenschaft nötig.
In ihrer Freizeit näht Christina Trikots
für die Wettkämpfe der kleinen Sportlerinnen.
Die Mädchen lieben die bunten Kostüme.
Und guck mal, das ist meins.
Das habe ich angehabt
bei meinem Wettkampf.
Das ist supersentimental für mich.
Mit diesem Trikot startete 2001
Christinas Karriere im Phantasialand.
Damals an ihrer Seite:
vier weitere Sportlerinnen aus ihrer Heimat.
Seitdem sind viele neue bulgarische Artisten
und Künstler gekommen,
andere sind gegangen –
wie üblich in diesem Geschäft.
Sie aber ist geblieben.
Denn der Park ist ihr Leben, sagt sie.
Auch ihren Ehemann
hat sie hier kennengelernt:
einen Stuntman aus Großbritannien.
Im Jahr 2005 haben wir geheiratet.
Und seitdem fühlt sich das Leben
wie Urlaub an.
Das Leben mit meiner Frau ist sehr leicht:
glückliche Frau, glückliches Leben.
Und du hast auch Glück mit mir.
Ja, habe ich!
Paul und Christina sind zufrieden.
Deutschland hat ihnen vieles gegeben.
Nur eins könnte noch besser werden.
Ich wünsche mir, dass man den Migranten
mehr Möglichkeiten gibt,
sich authentischer zu fühlen.
Hier im Park ist es nicht von Bedeutung,
woher du kommst.
Aber im Alltag spürt man schon,
dass das eine Rolle spielt.
Wenn man das verändern könnte,
wäre das toll.
Und gleich geht es zur nächsten Show –
nicht nur beruflich.
Denn unser Leben ist eine Bühne,
wie Christina sagt.